Kubernetes makes it possible to containerize
applications and simplifies deployment to
production. Bogdan Stashchuk will teach you
everything you need to know to get started
with Kubernetes. Welcome to the Kubernetes For
Beginners. Kubernetes is the defacto standard for
deployment of the containerized applications
into production. Kubernetes is open source
and therefore it is free for use. Let me first
introduce myself before we will start this course.
My name is Bogdan Stashchuk and I have been using
Docker and Kubernetes multiple years on practice.
And I have deployed real world applications
into production using Kubernetes. Also,
I'm teaching online and on my personal websites
that shoe.com You could find all courses which
I teach. Now let's get started with Kubernetes
for beginners, and I would like to start with
course plan. So what is included in this course,
we will start by talking about terminology and
the key features of the Kubernetes. And
you'll learn what is Kubernetes cluster,
what is node and what the sport and the what
Kubernetes essentially does. Afterwards,
we will immediately dive into the practice and
we will build small Kubernetes cluster locally on
our computers. And afterwards using such cluster
we will create and scale different deployments.
Also, we will build a custom Docker
image, push it to Docker Hub,
and afterwards create Kubernetes deployment
based on this customly built Docker image.
Other than that, we will also create services and
deployments in Kubernetes using Yamo configuration
files. Also, we will connect different
deployments together because it's very common
situation when you have to connect different
applications together over the network.
And Kubernetes allows of course to do that. And
also finally, we will change container runtime
from the Docker to CRI o because Kubernetes
is not bound to Docker. It also supports
other container runtimes like CRI O and
container D. And you could use Kubernetes
absolutely without Docker. One single prerequisite
for this course is your familiarity with Docker,
I assume that you know what is Docker container
and how to create different containers.
Alright, so let's get started with this course.
And I would like to start with definition
Kubernetes is a container orchestration
system. using Docker, you could of course
create container on any computer. But of course,
if you want to create multiple containers
on different computers on different servers, you
could get into the troubles. Kubernetes allows you
to create the containers on different
servers, either physical or virtual.
And all of that is done automatically without
your intervention. You just tell Kubernetes how
many containers you would like to create
based on a specific image. Kubernetes is
relatively alone good word, and it consists of
10 different letters. BUT IT professionals and
software developers are relatively lazy
people and they don't like to type much.
That's why search alone award is usually shortened
just to three characters. But how is it done?
Let's have a look at this word. between k and
s, there are actually eight different letters.
So number eight, that's why loan award Kubernetes
would be shortened just to three characters,
K eight s. So eight represents simply quantity of
the letters between starting and ending collateral
Simple as that. Knowing this very simple tweak
we could go on. And now let me explain to you
what Kubra this takes care of. So Kubernetes takes
care of automatic deployment of the containerized
applications across different servers. And those
servers could be either bare metal or physical
servers or virtual servers. Virtual Servers
option is of course more common nowadays,
and almost no one uses now bare metal servers.
So Kubernetes allows you to perform automated
deployments across different servers that could
be located even in different parts of the world.
Other than that, Kubernetes also takes
care of distribution of the Lord across
those multiple servers. And this allows
you to use your resources efficiently
and avoid under utilization or
over utilization of the resources.
Also Kubernetes takes care of the auto
scaling of the deployed applications in case
you need to increase for example, quantity of the
containers which have to be created on different
servers. And all that done automatically. You
just tell when you want to scale up or down. Also,
Kubernetes takes care of the monitoring and
health check of the containers. And in case
some containers fail for some reasons Kubernetes
could automatically replace failed containers
and all of the done without your intervention. As
I just told you Kubernetes deploys containerized
applications and therefore it has to use a
specific container runtime. And Dogra is just
one of the possible options Kubernetes nowadays,
support such container runtimes Docker,
CRI O, and container D, and search container
runtime, for example as Docker or CRI o must
be running on each of the servers which
are included in the Kubernetes cluster.
And main outcome here is that Kubernetes
could be utilized even without Docker at all.
It supports other container runtimes like CRI O
and container D. And at the end of this course,
I'll demonstrate to you how to change
container run time and move from Docker
for example to CRI O. So now let's get started
with terminology and architecture of Kubernetes.
And let's start with port both is the smallest
unit in the Kubernetes world in Dhaka rolled
container is smallest unit in Kubernetes
pod is the smallest possible unit and
containers are created inside of the pod. So
both an atomic is following inside of the pod,
there are could be containers, either one
or even several containers. Also, there are
shared volumes and shared network resources for
example, a shared IP address. This means that
all containers inside of the same pod
share volumes and share IP address.
And you must keep that in mind if you want to
create multiple containers inside of the same
port. Most common scenario of course is to have
just a single container per port. But sometimes
when the containers have to be tightened together
and they heavily depend on each other and they
could exist in the same namespace, it is possible
to grade several containers in the same port.
But again, single container per
port is the most common use case.
Also please keep in mind that each port must be
located on the same Sarah it is not possible to
spread the containers from one port across
different servers in the Kubernetes cluster,
one pot one server. So let's now have a look at
that Kubernetes cluster what is that Kubernetes
cluster consists of nodes node is actually Sarah
either bare metal server or virtual server. And
you could include multiple saij servers into the
Kubernetes cluster and they would be located in
different data centers in different parts of the
world. But usually nodes which belong to the same
Kubernetes cluster are located close to each other
in order to perform all jobs more efficiently.
Inside of the node, there are ports both is again
the smallest possible unit in the Kubernetes
and inside of each port, there are
containers usually single container per port
and such boards are graded on different nodes
and all of that is done automatically for you
Kubernetes does this job. But of course your job
is to create such nodes and create clusters based
on those nodes. Nodes will not automatically
Form class or without your intervention.
But after such initial configuration,
everything will be automated and Kubernetes
will automatically deploy both on different
nodes. But how those nodes actually communicate
with the Charles or and how are they managed.
In a Kubernetes cluster there was master node
and other nodes in the cluster are called worker
nodes. and master node actually manages worker
nodes. And if Master nodes job to distribute
for example, load across other worker nodes
and all boards, which are related to your
applications are deployed on worker nodes,
master node runs only system ports,
which are responsible for actual
work of the Kubernetes cluster in general,
we could also say that master node in the
Kubernetes cluster is actually control plane,
and it does not run your client applications.
So, which services actually run on different
nodes? Let's have a look at this diagram.
There are such services as cubelet, cube proxy
and container runtime and those services are
present on each node in a Kubernetes cluster.
You already know what is the container runtime
container runtime runs actual containers inside
of each node, and that there are such container
runtimes as Docker CRI o or container D.
There is also such service as cubelet. And
such service on each worker node communicates
with a BI Server service on the master node.
A Di server service is main point of communication
between different nodes in the Kubernetes world.
Cube proxy which is present on each node as
well is responsible for network communication
inside of each node and between nodes. Also,
there are other services which are present
on master node. And they are scheduler and
such service is responsible for planning
and distribution of the Lord between
different nodes in the classroom.
Also, there was Cube controller manager, and this
single point which controls everything actually in
the Kubernetes cluster. And it controls actually
what happens on each of the nodes in the cluster.
Also, there was cloud controller manager. And his
job is interaction with cloud service provider
where you actually run your Kubernetes cluster,
because usually you don't create such clusters
yourself using just your own servers. Instead,
you could very easily run the Kubernetes
cluster from one of the cloud providers,
which actually perform almost automated
creation of all nodes and the connections
between such nodes. And for that you have
to run cloud controller manager service on that
master node. Also, for example, if you want to
create the deployment of your application inside
of the Kubernetes cluster, which will be opened
to outside world and allow connections from
outside, you could create also load balancer IP
addresses. And those load balancers. IP addresses
are usually provided by specific cloud providers.
Also a master node there is such service as
etcd. And this is a service which actually stores
all logs related to operation of entire Kubernetes
cluster. And such logs are stored there as key
value pairs. Also, there are other services which
are running on master node, for example, a DNS
service which is responsible for names resolution,
entire Kubernetes cluster. And for instance,
using a DNS service, you could connect to specific
deployment by the name of the corresponding
deployment service. And in such way, you could
connect different deployments with a job or
that's a different services which are running on
different nodes in the Kubernetes cluster. And the
main service on the master node is API Sarah.
And by the way, using this API server service,
you could actually manage an entire Kubernetes
cluster. How is it done? It is done by using
cube CTL or cube control. And cube
control is a separate command line
tool, which allows you to connect to specific
Kubernetes cluster and manage it remotely.
And cube CTL could be running even on your local
computer. And using such a cube CTL tool you could
manage a remote Kubernetes cluster. And using
such tool you actually connect using REST API
to a API server service on the master node. And
such communication happens over HTTPS. By the way,
other nodes in the cluster I mean worker nodes
communicate with master node in the same fashion.
It means that using such a cube CTL tool, you
could manage any remote Kubernetes cluster.
This eat for Kubernetes architecture overview,
and now you know that the Kubernetes cluster
consists of the nodes, and the one of the nodes
is master node, and it manages our other nodes,
which are called worker nodes. On each node,
there are boards and the boards are graded
automatically by Kubernetes. And inside of
the port, there are containers, usually just
single container port. Also, please keep in
mind that all containers inside of the port
share namespace as of that port, like volumes or
network IP address. Also, both our smallest units
in Kubernetes, and the ports could be created that
could be removed could be moved from one node to
another. This happens automatically without
your intervention. But you have to design
your application with this mind, both could be
deleted on any moment of time. Also, there are
different services which are running on different
nodes. For example, API server service is central
point of communication between master node and
other worker nodes. And also using such a BI
service service, you actually could manage actual
Kubernetes cluster using cube CTL tool, which has
to be installed, for example, on your computer
if you perform management from your computer.
Alright, I don't want to dive deeper into
the details of the Kubernetes because
this is very complicated tool. And I want
to focus more on practical tasks instead.
That's why now after such overview, we will dive
together with you into the practice and perform
different practical tasks together. For example,
we will create deployments, services, scale
deployments, create custom Docker image and create
the deployment based on that image, and so on.
In order to perform all practical tasks together
with me, you have to install some programs
on your computer. And now when we talk about
required software, and first we have to create
actual Kubernetes cluster, where we will
create different deployments. Of course,
you could create cluster using services from one
of the cloud providers like Amazon Web Services,
or Google Cloud, but you have to pay for such
service. If you want free solution, you could
create class for locally on your computer.
And for that there was such tool as mini cube.
And such tool will essentially create just
a single node cluster. And this node will
be both worker node and master node. But
for test deployments, and as a playground,
it works pretty nice and all that is free
and will be running on your local computer.
In order to run mini cube successfully, you have
to utilize virtual machine or container manager.
And there are following virtual machine
or container managers which are supported
VirtualBox, VMware, Docker, Hyper V, or
parallels. There are also other options available.
But you have to utilize one of such options.
In order to actually create the virtual node,
which will run all both in
your Kubernetes cluster.
I suggest you to go ahead with Hyper V, if you're
a Windows user. And if you're a Mac OS user,
you could go ahead with welchol box it is free
and open source or you could utilize VMware or
parallels. By the way, there was also an option to
run mini cube as container inside of the Docker.
Of course, if you have Docker already installed
on your computer, you could utilize it in order
to create a Kubernetes cluster using mini cube
and essentially it will create a separate Docker
container and inside of that container all both
will be created. But I personally don't recommend
to you to go ahead with Docker option because
there were some limitations. For example, I was
not able to change the container runtime inside
of the Docker container to CRI or container D.
And therefore I recommend to you to go ahead
with other options which are mentioned here.
By the way, Hyper V is available on Windows
computers out of the box and And you could
utilize it as Butoh Machine Manager for running
mini cube node. To summarize using mini cube,
you will create a single node Kubernetes
cluster. But as I mentioned before,
you have to use a specific tool in order to manage
this cluster. And this tool is called cube CTL.
By the way, cube CTL is included in mini cube.
But if you want to use such included version,
you have to enter mini cube cube CTL commands,
it is not convenient. Therefore, I recommend to
you to install cube CTL separately. And using
separate installation, you will be able, of
course to manage other Kubernetes clusters, which
are located for example, at Amazon Web Services.
So, cube CTL is also one of the programs which you
have to install on your computer. Certainly, I'll
explain to you how to install mini cube and cube
CTL. Other than that, we will also do some coding
in this practical course. And for that you have
to use one of the code editors and I recommend
to you to install Visual Studio code, it is open
source and free for use. And if you have not yet
installed it, please go ahead and install it.
Also, it has many different extensions, and one
of them is Kubernetes extension. And using such
extension you could very fast great for instance
Yamo configuration files for your deployments
and services in Kubernetes. That's all what you
need for this course mini cube cube CTL and Visual
Studio code. Now let's get started with practical
part. And I hope you'll enjoy this course. And we
will start with the installation of the mini cube
and cube CTL. Alright guys now let's get started
with practical part of the course. And we will
start by installing communicate cube along with
cube CTL. But first, I would like to ask you to
navigate to kubernetes.io. This is the main site
dedicated to Kubernetes in general and it has
all documentation related to configuration of the
mini cube clusters creation of deployments, etc.
Please click here on documentation. And here
in the left section go to getting started.
And here you could read how you
could create a learning environment.
Along with that you could also find information
how to create a production environment. But we are
interested now in creation of the local Kubernetes
cluster. And for that we will utilize mini cube.
And also we will install tube CTL. That's why a
police click here on this hyperlink install tools.
And do find instructions how to install cube CTL
on different operating systems, please choose
yours. I'll choose Mac OS here. And if you're a
Mac OS user, you could very easily install cube
CTL using homebrew let me demonstrate to you how
to do that. Let me click on this option. Run the
installation command brew install cube CTL Let me
copy this command and open up terminal I'm using
item to a Mac and paste this command here. Let's
go ahead and install cube CTL. The warden package
and cube CTL was installed. Let me check version
of the cube CTL. For that I could utilize
this command cube CTL version, there's
desk client. Let me enter it here.
And I see that the cube CTL was installed
successfully. And here was client version
major one and minor 22. And here was
actually exact version which was installed.
Alright, if you're a Windows user, I recommend
to you to install cube CTL using package manager,
you could go to install and setup cube CTL on
Windows and here choose option install on Windows
using chocolaty or scoop. Click on this option
and here you'll find instructions how to install
different packages using chocolaty package manager
or scoop command line installer, I recommend to
you to install chocolaty Package Manager. In order
to do that, please open up this link here and find
instructions how to install this package manager
for Windows. Using the same package manager you
could very easily install mini cube as well. So
please go ahead and install this package manager
and afterwards, follow those instructions on how
to install cube CTL on Windows. Use just a single
command this one and afterwards, verify that cube
CTL is available using this command. All right.
After this, I assume that cube CTL is
already available on your computers.
And now let's go ahead and install mini cube. Go
back to Getting Started page and here scroll down
to learning environment and click on hyperlink
installed tools. This one, you will find the game
that you have to install cube CTL. That's what we
just did together. And if you scroll down, you'll
find options which you could utilize in order to
create a local Kubernetes cluster for learning and
testing purposes. Nowadays, there are such tools
as kind, and it allows you to create Kubernetes
cluster locally on your computer, but it requires
Docker. Also, there is mini cube and cube ADM.
We will utilize mini cube throughout this course.
That's why let's get started with installation
of the mini cube. It does not require Docker.
But it does require one of the virtual machine
managers like Hyper V parallels. Or if you want,
you could also utilize Docker, please navigate to
this link mini cube, you could simply enter mini
cube in the Google search bar and click on the
first result in the output. And here you'll find
documentation how to get started with mini cube,
please click on this link get started. And
here you could read about mini cube and
it will basically create a Kubernetes
cluster locally on your computer.
And it will contain just a single node which
will act both as master node and worker node.
And all what you need in order to create such a
cluster is just single command mini cube start
simple as that. But in order to successfully
create a mini cube cluster, you have to install
one of the container or your doll machine managers
such as Docker, HyperCard, Hyper V parallels and
so on. I told you before that if you're a Windows
user, I recommend to you to utilize Hyper V
because it is available on Windows out of the box.
If you're a Mac user, I recommend to you to go
ahead either with will toolbox option or parallels
or VMware Fusion beautiful box is free for us.
Therefore, if you don't want to buy anything for
Virtual Machine Manager, I recommend you to go
ahead with this option. Also, it is possible to
create mini cube cluster inside of the container
Docker container and for that you could just
install Docker. But I personally don't recommend
to you to go ahead with this option because
there are some limitations in running such
a glass door inside of the Docker container. All
right here below you could find out how to install
mini cube on different operating systems Linux,
Mac OS and Windows. If you're a Windows user,
you could similarly as with cube CTL utilize choco
latte, please select this option and enter just
single command choco install mini cube simple
as that and you'll get mini cube installed
on a Windows computer but I am using Mac OS
That's why I'll select this option and select
homebrew and in order to install mini cube using
brew, I could simply enter just one command brew
install mini cube. Let me go ahead and install
it using brew. Let's go back to terminal and
here based command brew install mini cube. Let's
wait a bit until this installed. Alright mini cube
was installed and now I could verify its version
mini cube version. Here was version in my case
and you could also enter mini cube HELP command in
order to find the list of all available commands
in mini cube. And if you scroll up, you'll find
out how to start a local Kubernetes cluster,
get status of the local Kubernetes cluster,
stop glass or delete and open dashboard.
Also you could pause and unpause Kubernetes
cluster right now let's create the actual cluster
I assume that now you have also installed mini
cube and cube CTL. Those tools are two separate
tools. That's why they are available as two
separate commands mini cube and cube CTL.
And now let's go ahead and create a Kubernetes
cluster. For that please utilize command mini cube
start but first let's enter mini cube status in
order to check the current status of the cluster
mini cube status. Here I see
that profile mini cube not found
around mini cube profile these two profiles
and also ice In order to start cluster,
I have to run mini cube start command. That's what
we are about to do right now, let's create cluster
mini cube start. And here I would like to ask
you to start the mini cube cluster with option.
And this option will be driver, and you should
write with two dashes, that's the driver. And here
will be equal sign. And after it, you have to
specify virtual machine or container Manager,
which you would utilize in order to create
mini cube cluster. I mentioned before that
if you're a Windows user, I recommend to you to
use Hyper V. Therefore, if you're on Windows,
simply enter here, Hyper V like that all lowercase
without dash, there's this driver equal sign Hyper
V. If you're a Mac OS user, you could go
ahead with any of those options VirtualBox
parallels or VMware Fusion, I will utilize
VirtualBox. If you don't have your toolbox,
please go ahead and install it and are here
your toolbox and click on the first link here.
Your toolbox is free. And here is the link where
you could download your toolbox. So if you don't
have your toolbox, and if you're a Mac OS user,
please go ahead and download your toolbox.
Right, I already have your toolbox
installed. That's why I will simply specify
it as bio for that driver option
here. So I will type Vertol box.
Let's go ahead and create mini cube cluster inside
of the VirtualBox virtual machine in my case,
creating your toolbox virtual machine quantity
of CPUs memory and disk. It will take a while
Let me wait a bit virtual machine was created.
And now I see message preparing Kubernetes
on Docker. And it means that by default, we
will utilize Docker container runtime for
running actual containers inside of the Kubernetes
cluster. Here I see step generating certificates
and keys booting up control plane. And finally at
the end, I see done cube CTL is not configured to
use mini cube cluster. And that means that you
don't need to do anything in order to connect
from cube CTL to actual mini cube cluster. This
connection was created automatically for you
during creation of the mini cube cluster.
Also, in my case, I see such a warning,
you have selected your toolbox driver, but
there are better options for better performance
and support consider using a different driver
HyperCard parallels or VMware. Now let's actually
verify the status of this Kubernetes cluster. And
for that you could enter command mini cube status.
And you should find out that host is ironic
cubelet is running API server is running and
cube config is configured. That's normal status
of the mini cube cluster. And now we are actually
able to create Deployment Services at cetera
inside of this mini cube cluster. Also, I would
like to mention that I don't have Docker running
right now. I actually have it installed on this
computer. But over here in the icons bar I don't
see Docker icon, it means that now Kubernetes on
my local computer does not utilize actual dog or
installation on my computer. But there is Docker
which is running inside of the mini cube node.
And that's what we will check right now. So as you
already know, each node in the Kubernetes cluster
is just server either virtual or physical. In our
case, we have created a virtual server and you
could connect to any server by using SSH protocol.
And in order to connect via SSH, we first need
to find out which IP address was assigned to
Kubernetes node. Mini cube provides command
for that. Simply type mini cube IP and you'll
see which IP address was assigned to a virtual
machine which is running our Kubernetes node which
was created by mini cube he was a address in my
case, simply grab this IP address and afterwards,
type SSH Docker it is username which is default
username for such node such beautiful Sarah
and after add sign based a balance of mini
cube note and afterwards please press enter
you will be presented with fingerprint please
go ahead and The type here as withdrawals such
a fingerprint. And afterwards you will be prompted
for a password default password for minikube. Your
toe machine is DC user, please go ahead and type
it here. So user name is darker and password is DC
user password was entered. And now I
see welcome prompt from the mini cube
Sarah. Now I am inside of the Kubernetes node.
And first command which I would like to ask
you to enter here is docker ps. Such command
will list you all run in Docker containers.
And here are a bunch of different containers
which were created inside of the Kubernetes node.
And again, please recap that Docker is
default container runtime for Kubernetes.
There are other container runtimes, such as CRI
O and container D. But here we see that there
are a bunch of different containers, which were
created by Docker inside of the mini cube note.
And for instance, here I see such container as
the cube API server, cube scheduler and so on.
Recap that we discussed with you different
services which are running on master nodes
and worker nodes. And those services are actually
running inside of the containers, as you see right
now here. Also, there are such containers as the
cube proxy storage provisioner, or, for instance,
core DNS. And again, every container has its
own purpose. That's how you could verify which
containers were created inside of the Kubernetes
node. But if I enter here a cube CTL command, I
will see error cube CTL command not found because
cube CTL command is not available inside of the
Kubernetes node cube CTL is external tool which
is used in order to manage Kubernetes cluster
this way, let's now go out of this SSH connection
connection was closed. And now let's utilize cube
CTL command here of growth cube CTL is available
locally on our computers because we have installed
cube CTL before let's first check class for info
cube CTL cluster this info and I get following
output Kubernetes control plane is running. And
here I see IP address which we just saw after
entering mini cube IP command. In your case,
of course such IP address will be different.
And also I see that core DNS service is running
as well. It means that now we are able actually to
create Deployment Services and cetera on our
Kubernetes cluster. But first let's list nodes
which are available in our Kubernetes cluster.
For that please enter command cube CTL get
nodes. And here I see just single node because
mini cube create single node cluster he was
name of such node status is ready. And here are
roles control plane and master. We'll get that
now inside of our mini cube cluster. This single
node acts both as master node and worker node and
on the worker node Kubernetes creates different
bolts related to your deployments which you deploy
in a Kubernetes cluster. Now let me check which
ports are available or right now in this cluster.
For that let's enter command cube CTL get
pods and now I see output no resources
found in default namespace. Let's list
all namespaces which are available
now in this Kubernetes cluster. For that please
enter command cube CTL get name spaces like that.
And I see several namespaces like default cube
node lease cube public and cube system namespaces
are used in Kubernetes in order to group
different resources and configuration objects.
And if you enter simply cube CTL get pods you will
see only ports available inside of the default
namespace here. And by the way, all ports which
will create throughout the scores will be great
in default namespace, but we have not yet
created any ports so far. That's why let's
try to find out which ports are running inside of
our other namespaces for instance cube system. In
order to list ports in a specific namespace,
you have to utilize namespace option. So cube
CTL. Get pods. There's the namespace, equal sign
and here enter cube system. Let's go ahead and run
this command. And now here in this namespace
cube system, I see such boards as gordianus
etcd, which stores all logs of entire Kubernetes
cluster, cube, API server, Cube controller, cube,
proxy, cube schedule, and storage provisioner. All
those bolts are system balls, which are running on
this master note. Alright, this is how we could
find out which ports are running right now in our
Kubernetes cluster. Now let's go ahead and create
both manually. And for that we could utilize
command which is similar to docker run command.
But with docker run command, you could create
just a single Docker container here or you could
utilize cube CTL Run command in order to create
just single port. Let's do that cube CTL run here
will be named. Let's for instance, utilize nginx
Docker image which is available at Docker Hub.
For that let's enter here name of the port Nginx.
And afterwards, let's add option image and
its value will be Ingenix Ingenix. Here
is name of the Docker image which will be pulled
automatically and new container will be created
based on this image and this container will
be running inside of the Kubernetes port.
Let's go ahead and see what will happen. Cube
CTL Iran Ingenix does this image equal sign
Ingenix and here I see output port Ingenix.
Great. Let's enter command cube CTL get pots.
And here I see now single port nginx it is not
yet ready. And instead of his container created.
Let's enter same command again cube CTL get pods
and now I see that this board is now run it is
ready and it status is run. Of course it took
some time in order to create such a pod because
inside of it there was nginx container
and Docker inside of the Kubernetes node
was actually requested to pull nginx image from
Docker Hub and create corresponding container
based on the search image Ingenix. Let us know
find out the details of this specific port was
named Nginx. This name we specified manually
here. For that please enter command cube CTL
describe port and here will be name of the port,
which you would like to describe get details about
here will be Ingenix. It is name of the run port.
And here are many different details related to
this specific port. Let me scroll a bit up. And
here I'll find out such information as namespace
this port belongs to and it was automatically
assigned to default namespace. That's why we were
able to see it in the list when we entered command
cube CTL get pods because such command lists
all both inside of the default namespace. Here is
information about node where such specific port
was created or kept that Kubernetes automatically
distributes a load across all nodes worker nodes
inside of the cluster and it selects specific node
for a specific board contents information about
the node where this particular port was created.
In our single node cluster of course, you will
see the same node each time when you create
any port and here was IP address of such node
here with start time here are labels status
is running. And here is a B address which
was assigned to this particular port
172 17 03. But please know that now we
will not be able to connect to this particular
port using such internal IP address or the port.
In order to be able to connect to ports,
you have to create services in Kubernetes.
And that's what we'll look at a bit later.
Here or below, you could also find out which
containers were created inside of this port. And
there was just a single container here was ID
of such container here was long ID here was image
which was utilized for this particular container.
And that's that image which was specified using
dash dash Image option when we created new port.
Here was image ID and it is ID of the image from
the Docker hub because by default Kubernetes pulls
all images from the Docker Hub. Of course, it's
possible to configure Kubernetes to pull images
from other repos. Recording services, but default
is Docker Hub. Alright, this are the tales about
this particular port. And we find out that there
was a B address assigned to this port, there was
container which was created inside of this port.
And here are logs related to creation of this
particular port. You see that this particular port
was successfully assigned to minute you note here
was message about pulling image engine X from
the Docker Hub successfully pulled image created
Container Engine X and started container Ingenix.
And it means that now there was nginx container
running inside of the grid port. Again, you could
find the list of all boats by entering command
cube CTL get pods, and here was single board
available right now in the default namespace. Now,
let's quickly go back again inside of the
Kubernetes mini cube node, and least again,
Docker containers and we will find out that now
there was one more container which was created
in the engine export. So using up arrow, I could
go back to the SSH command which I entered before.
Here it is and connect to this node again. Enter
TC user password. And let's enter here a docker
ps. But now let's filter output by name ngi
NX. And now I will find out that there are two
different containers here was first one and here's
the second one which are related to engine X.
Here is the name of the thrust container,
K eight s nginx nginx default and so on.
And also there was one more container
GAE eight s port nginx default and so on.
And this second container is called
boss container. Here you see that
inside of the container balls executable was
actually launched one container was graded
and if Dogra is a container runtime in
Kubernetes, there are always such both containers,
which are created for each specific port. And
such post containers are created in order to
let's say look namespace of specific port. And
we discussed before that all containers inside
of the same board actually share namespaces. And
this container, which is actually run in our nginx
web server would be stopped could be recreated by
Kubernetes. But both remains untouched. And this
second container which is called boss container
is required to keep namespace of the port.
Alright, that's how containers look right now.
And let's actually connect to this container
where we are running nginx service. In order
to connect to container you could use either ID
this one or this name. Let's connect to
container by this ID please select this
container note pause container. And let's enter
command Docker Exec. This ID here was ID of the
container. And let's connect this container using
SHA executable. Now I'm inside of the container.
Let's check its hostname. Ingenix. It is name of
the board actually. And the same name was assigned
to this container. And let's also check IP address
of this container here was such a address 172 17
03. And that's that IP address which we saw
in the details of the port. Now let's try to
connect to web server which is running inside of
this container where we are currently in by using
this IP address. And for that we could utilize
see URL command and here are based on IP address
of this particular container. Regardless,
we are inside of the nginx container.
Let's try to make connection. And here I see
Welcome to nginx page which was returned by this
web server. It means that nginx web server is up
and running. Let's go out of this container and
now we are still inside of the Kubernetes node.
Okay but we made SSH connection to it. And now
let's exit from this connection as well like that.
And now let's enter the following command cube CTL
get pods this all white and with such option
you will find also IP address of particular
port in this output Here's the same IP address,
which we just saw inside of the container.
Let's now try to connect to such a P address from
our computer, our computer is external relative to
our Kubernetes cluster, because Kubernetes
node is running inside of the virtual machine.
And this IP address was assigned by Docker
to particular container inside of the node.
Let's try to connect to such IP address, I could
utilize the same command CRL. Here it is available
on Mac. Or you could simply open up a web browser
and connect to this IP address. And you'll find
out that you will not be able to connect to
engine X container like that. Because as I told
you before, such IP address is internal IP address
of the port and you're not able to connect to such
port from outside rolled outside of the classroom.
Great. That's how we created very first board in
our Kubernetes cluster. And we also explored the
tail of switchboard. And I hope that now it is
clear to you what happens when you create a board
inside of the port Kubernetes grades container.
And in order to create container it
has to pull image from the Docker Hub.
And in our example nginx image was pulled and
new container was created based on that image.
Also, we went inside of the container and verify
that nginx web server is now actually running.
But we are not able to connect to such port from
the outside, because now it has only internal IP
address which was assigned by the Docker. But of
course creation of the port using cube CTL Run
command is not really convenient, because you're
not able to scale. And for example, increase
quantity of the ports, there was just a single
port, which we created using cube CTL Run command.
That's why now let's simply delete created
port for that there is command cube CTL Delete.
Next will be name of the resource we would like
to delete and the Dysport and here will be name
of the port in our example Ingenix because we
specified site name for the port manually when
we entered the cube CTL Run command. So let's
go ahead and delete Sasha port bought Ingenix
deleted, cube CTL get pods and there are no
resources found in default namespace and such port
is simply gone. And all volumes all namespaces
related to this particular port were removed.
Great. You might notice that we entered cube
CTL command multiple times and in my opinion,
such command is relatively long. And we are able
to create alias for such command in order to save
some time in the future. And we could alias
cube CTL command to just a single letter K.
And afterwards we'll enter such commands as K
get ports. But now if I enter a search command,
I'll get the command not found error
because I have not yet created any aliases.
On Linux like operating systems, you could very
easily create aliases by entering command alias.
Next will be an alias for the command then equal
sign and after equal sign in double quotes you
could write command which you would like to alias
in our example cube CTL if you are a Windows user
and if you are using PowerShell this command will
not work there. If you want to get the similar to
mine experience in command line I recommend to
you to install Git Bash. In order to install
it please navigate to get SCM comm and simply
download Git. If get is already installed on your
Windows computer, you already have access to Git
Bash, it is another terminal. If you don't have
Git installed please go to Windows section here
and download git for windows here are different
links to eat. And after installation please open
Git Bash terminal instead of the power shell. So
I already have alias command available in this
terminal on Mac OS. Therefore I will be able
to create such an alias let's create LS LS was
created and now I'm able to utilize just a short
version of the Command K get pods and now I see
output no resources found in default namespace.
From this point on I will utilize such
short version of the cube CTL command
but please notice that such alias will leave only
during this session in the terminal. After a lot
of the computer or when you open up another
terminal session. This alias will be gone.
If you want I'd like to create a permanent
alias, of course, it is possible to do,
in order to perform such a task, you have to
edit your shell configuration profile. But I will
not do that right now, it's enough to have just
temporal alias. Great. Now, let's continue. As I
mentioned before, it is not convenient to create
separate ports inside of the Kubernetes cluster,
because you're not able to scale
and increase quantity of the ports.
Therefore, the most common way to create
multiple ports, when you're able to
increase quantity of the ports, degrees quantity,
modify configuration, etc, is by using deployment.
And deployment will be responsible for creation
of the actual ports. But please notice that all
ports inside of the deployment will be the same,
exactly the same. But you could create multiple
copies of the same board and distribute load
across different nodes in the Kubernetes cluster,
this purpose of the deployment. Now let's
go ahead and create deployment. And we will
utilize same image which we utilized before it is
nginx image. And also afterwards, we will increase
quantity of the ports in this deployment. And
also we'll create a service for this deployment
in order to be able to connect to our deployment
from external rolled. Let's go ahead and create
size deployment. And for that, we will
utilize command cube CTL, create deployment,
we already alias the cube CTL command. That's
why I will enter key create deployment.
And next will be the name of the deployment.
Let's name it Ingenix. And afterwards,
let's specify also image similarly, as we did in
cube CTL, Run command. And here after equal sign
will be the name of the image we would like to
utilize for this deployment. And let's enter here
Nginx. In order to avoid any confusion, let's
modify the name of this deployment. And let's
name it for instance Ingenix. That deployment like
that, let's go ahead and create this deployment.
deployment was created with ant or Command
K get deployments. He was single deployment,
it is ready and up to date. And let's enter K get
pods. And now I see that there is no single board
which is managed by this particular deployment.
And such a Board was created automatically
after we created such deployment. And now this
port is managed by this deployment. There was
just single port at the moment. And of course
disposable to scale quantity of the ports and
the degrees wanted to have the port for instance
235 and so on. But first, before doing that,
let's read the details about size deployment.
And for that let's enter command gay describe
deployment. And here will be name
of the deployment nginx deployment.
Here are the details have created deployment.
Let's scroll a bit up. And here at the beginning
of the output I see name of the deployment engine
X deployment. That's that name, which was given
to this deployment by us here was namespace where
our sash deployment was created default namespace
below, you'll see that Kubernetes automatically
assigned all labels to this particular deployment.
And there was just single label up equal sign
engine X deployment. Also there are annotations,
again, created automatically here was annotation.
And he was also selector selectors are used
in order to connect boards with the blueprints.
Because in Kubernetes, boards and deployments
are actually separate objects. And we have to
know how to assign specific boards to particular
deployments. And here we see selector up equals
sign nginx deployment and for a particular port,
which was automatically created and assigned
to this deployment, we will find a label with
the same value up equal sign nginx deployment,
we will have a look at that just in a minute.
Also, there was a replica field and here you could
find information about quantity of the boards,
which are desired by this deployment and
actual quantity of the ports which are running
here was just single port single replica which is
desired, one updated one total and one available.
It means that now there was one port
which is assigned to this deployment
He was also strategy type rolling update, which
tells how to perform updates of deployments.
We will get back to it a bit later in this course.
And also below, you will find other details
about this particular deployment. Here you'll
find all the details about both template.
And as I just told you, you'll find out
inside of the port corresponding label
up equal sign nginx deployment. And same
label is mentioned here in the selector
field in the deployment. And that's how the
deployment is connected to particular ports.
Also, if you scroll a bit down, you'll find actual
events related to this particular deployment.
And here we see single event scaling replica
set. But what is replica set a bit above you
see a new replica set nginx deployment and ID of
the replica set. And replica set actually manages
all balls related to deployment. And replica
set is a set of replicas of your application,
because you could create 510 100 different
boards in the same deployment. And all of them
are included in the replica set. And that's
why here you see that size replica set was
scaled up to one and one port was created in this
replica set. Great, this are the details about
this particular deployment. And now let's have
a look again, at the list of the ports get pods
here was just single port and notice its name.
It starts with the name of the replica set,
which we just discussed. And so in the
output of the details of the deployment,
nginx deployment and this hash, and afterwards,
there was specific hash for this particular port.
And if there are multiple ports in the same
deployment, which belongs to the same replica set,
you'll see same graphics here, but different
hashes here for different ports. Now,
there will be a single port, which is
ready, and we just grind. Also, we could
get the details about this particular port,
let's grab its name, and enter here gay describe
board. And here, let's paste corporate hash. And
here are the details about this particular port.
Let's scroll up. He was name of the
board it matches with this name.
It was assigned to default namespace same as
deployment. Here is node where this particular
pod is running right now, here are labels of
this particular port. And I see such label as
up nginx deployment and port template hash.
Notice that this hash is equal to this
hash. And it matches with ID of the replica
set. Also isis that was running here was IP
address of the board. And here I see that this is
controlled by specific replica set, replica set
nginx deployment. And here's a hash of the
replica set, which controls this particular port.
Also, here are the details about containers
which are running inside of the port. And
here was container ID and image which was used for
creation of the container in this particular port.
Also, at the end, you could find logs related to
the port, as we discussed before, successfully
assigned to specific node pooling, image
nginx and so on. Now, there was deployment.
And instead of deployment, there was a replica
set. And ports aren't managed by this deployment.
Now there was just single port. Great. Now let's
try to scale this deployment and increase quantity
of the ports inside of the deployment. Now there
was a single port for that we could utilize
following command cube CTL. Shortly, Kay in our
case scale, we would like to scale deployment.
Let's right here deployment. Name of the
deployment in our case is Nginx. That deployment.
And afterwards, let's specify one of the replicas
we would like to have in this deployment right
now. Now there will be a single replica. In order
to specify desired quantity of the replicas,
we could add here option replicas, then after
equal sign, specify quantity of the replicas.
Let's say we want to scale to five replicas. Let's
enter file here. And let's scale our deployment.
deployment was scaled and now let's enter command
gate get votes. And I see that there are four New
containers which are currently being created.
Here was one port, second, third and fourth
port. And this port is still run. In a moment,
you should see that all five bolts will be run.
Here they are. We just scaled our deployment to
five different replicas. And now there are five
different pods running right now inside of our
Kubernetes cluster. And notice how easy it is,
we did not create those balls manually Kubernetes
scaled this deployment automatically for us.
Notice that all those ports have the same prefix,
it is name of the replica set, all those ports
belong to. And those parts are different for
different ports. And again, all both are running.
Let's also read the details about those ports,
which will include IP addresses, let's add here,
option this all white. And I'll see that each
port has different IP address here or here, here,
here or here. And all those bolts were graded
just on single node mini cube, because again,
we're here just single node cluster. If you were
running multiple nodes, of course, a lot would be
distributed across different nodes. And you would
see that the Poles were assigned to different
nodes. Alright, now let's try to scale down
quantity of the replicas in this deployment. from
five to let's say three. Let's go back to this
command, K, scale deployment nginx deployment. And
here, let's specify I want to do the replicas as
three like that. deployment was scaled, let's get
boards. And I see that now there are only three
boards up and run, two ports were removed. Great.
Now let's try to connect to one of the ports. For
instance, this one was grabbed his IP address.
And before we already tried to connect to one of
the ports from our local computer, and again, our
local computer is external relative to Kubernetes
cluster, it is very, very important. Let's try to
connect to this IP address CRL and paste the
IP address and connection is not successful.
Let's now go inside of the node mini cube node
and try to connect to this port any of those ports
from inside of the node. And it will mean that we
are trying to connect to the port inside of the
cluster. Let's SSH again to our mini cube node
as a sage, Docker, apt and this IP address. In
your case, this IP is of course different password
is DC user. And now here, let's see URL and enter
IP address of one of the ports. Any port works
here. So let's see URL and I was able to connect
to a specific port by its IP address. Let's
try to connect to another port with another IP.
For instance list y 0.3. I'm not sure whether I
have such port running. Yes, I have. And I also
got response from such port with such a boundless
recap that now I'm located inside of the node.
And I am able to connect to ports which are
running on this specific note using IP addresses
of those ports. Let's exit from this node. And
again, let's list ports along with a address. So
I was able to connect to this port and this port
from the node. But of course such IP addresses
are assigned to both dynamically when you both are
created. And you should not rely on IP addresses
of the ports if you would like to connect to
specific port. Therefore, it's not convenient to
utilize such IP addresses. And you should utilize
some sort of other IP addresses which are managed
by Kubernetes and which allow you to connect
to any of the ports inside of the deployment.
Let me show you how to do that. In Kubernetes.
You have to create so called services if you would
like to connect to specific deployments using
specific IP addresses. And there are different
options available you could create so called
cluster IP and such IP address will be created
and assigned to specific deployment and you will
be able to connect to this specific deployment
all the inside of the cluster using this virtual
IP address. And Kubernetes will distribute a lot
across different ports which are assigned to
specific deployment But please know that such
API address will be just single IP address for
entire deployment. And of course, it is much more
convenient to use such API address than specific
IP addresses of the ports as we just tried.
Also, there was an option to create external IP
addresses to open deployment to outside world. And
it is possible to expose specific deployment to
the IP address of the node or use a load balancer
or get the inside of the Kubernetes cluster, it is
possible to have multiple nodes and both could be
distributed across different nodes. Therefore, the
most common solution is to have a load balancer IP
address, which will be just single for the entire
Kubernetes cluster for a specific deployment.
And you will be able to connect to your
deployment no matter where both are graded
using just a single external IP address. But such
load balancer IP addresses are usually assigned by
specific cloud provider like Amazon Web Services,
or Google Cloud. And such assignments are managed
by cloud controller manager is service which
is running on the master node. Let's now try to
create cluster IP for our deployment. And we will
create for that specific service. So we already
have deployment created, let's read the details
about size deployment, Kay, get deployments.
By the way, you could shorten such a long road
just to deploy like that get deployed. And here
was the name of our deployment. Now there
are three different ports, which are already
in this deployment. Let's now create a
service for this particular deployment.
And using a service, you could expose
a specific port from the deployment.
Now we are running three different ports.
And inside of each port, there was nginx
container. And by default nginx web server is
running at Port 80. It means that we have to
expose internal port 80 from the containers
to any other prod outside of the deployment.
And we could choose for instance, Port
8080. For this particular example,
in order to expose internal port from the
deployment ports, you should do device command
expose, let's enter a gay expose deployment.
Here will be name of the deployment, we would
like to create service for nginx deployment.
Here was the name of our deployment. Recap
that we don't mention here ports, we work with
deployments. And ports are managed by deployments.
So Let's expose deployment engine X deployment
here will be option port, let's specify a port
which we would like to utilize as external port
for our deployment. And let's set it to port 8080.
And also we have to add here target port, if
brought inside of the containers is different
from this prod which we specify right now here.
And in our example right now, brought inside of
the container is aged. That's why we have to add
here option does this target port equal sign 80
So we expose internal port from the
containers to external prod 88. And
we do that for the deployment heroes name of the
deployment. Alright, Let's expose nginx deployment
service engine is deployment was exposed and now
less least services for that there was command
gay get services. And now there are two services
throat service is default system service. It is
called Kubernetes type is cluster ID and here
is cluster IP address. And also here we see one
more serious nginx deployment. He was name he
was type cluster IP and here was cluster IP.
And this IP address is completely different
from the IP address assigned to the port's
this IP address is even from another network
IP addresses of the board's start from 172. And
here this IP address starts from 10 and this is a
virtual IP address which was created by Kubernetes
and it is just a single IP address which could
be used in order to connect to any of the ports
and such type cluster IP allows you to connect
to specific deployment in our example nginx
deployment only from inside of the Kubernetes
cluster. For instance, if in your Kubernetes
cluster, there was a database deployment, for
instance, there was MongoDB database or my SQL
database. And the search database should not be
available and accessible from outside rolled,
you could create cluster IP service for such
database deployment and other deployments
inside of your Kubernetes cluster, we'll be able
to connect to database deployment using cluster
IP. But again, session deployment will be hidden
from the outside world. But on other hand, if you
create any web service deployment, and it should
be available from outside, of course, you have
to expose it to outside world using node port or
load balancer. That's what we'll try a bit later.
cluster IP will be available
only inside of the cluster.
So here we see cluster IP address. Here it
is, and here is brought which was exposed
by our deployment. Also, you could get list of
services using short version of this command,
simply enter a gay get SVC, it is short version of
services SVC. And result will be the same. There
are now two different services with those last
three IP address this one for Kubernetes service,
and this one for nginx deployment service.
And now let's try to connect to our deployment
using this service. Let's grab this cluster IP.
And let's first try to connect to this cluster IP
address from our local computer. See URL and
paste this IP address. And after cold, let's
also add port which we exposed. It is external
port for our deployment. Internally, it will be
proxy to port 80 on each container. Let's try
whether this works on our local computer or not
CRL. And I see no response. That's what I just
told you. cluster IP address is not available
outside of the Kubernetes cluster. This behavior
of the cluster IP is just internally available IP
address, but you're able to access cluster IP from
any node. And let's try that. Let's SSH to our
node. Let me go back to this command, SSH Dogra
and the IP address of the node DC user. And let's
now try to connect to cluster IP from the node.
And here again, let's specify port 8080. And I see
result Welcome to Ingenix. And this response was
provided by one of the ports in the deployment.
Of course now from this output, I am not able
to recognize which port exactly answered me.
But this answer was provided by
one of the ports in the deployment.
I could try again. Again Again, and I get
answer from the ports in the deployment.
That's how it works. cluster IP is just single
IP which was graded as a service for particular
deployment. And you could utilize just single
IP in order to connect to any of the ports
and behind the scenes Kubernetes does all proxying
of the request to particular selected port and
it balances a lot across different ports in the
deployment. Alright, let's close this connection
endless no also read the tales about particular
service we'll get there with Command K get SVC
short version for get services and he was name
of the service which we create before. Let's take
this name and right now K describe service and
name of the service we would like to get details
about here was Gloucester IP which we just used
in order to connect to this series. Also there
was external abroad and here was targett port.
And here are three different endpoints. Those
endpoints indicate particular ports, which are
used for connections to this particular cluster
IP. So load will be balanced across those three
different ports. And notice everywhere here port
80. It is targeted broad for our service, Dysport,
ad is default port where Ingenix server is run. So
AD AD and AD also here You see type of the service
cluster IP, and selector here is also present up
equal sign Ingenix deployment. And that's how this
service is actually connected to particular ports.
All those ports also have particular label up
nginx deployment. And this label was created by
Kubernetes. Automatically, we did not specify
it, because we just created the deployment
using grid deployment command. And we
created a service using expose command.
Namespace here is default, same as for both and
deployment, which is called Nginx. Deployment.
Alright, that's it for this service. And
we exposed our deployment using cluster IP.
And cluster IP is only available inside of
the Kubernetes clusters. Now you know how to
create a port, how to create deployment, how to
scale deployment, and how to create a service
for a particular deployment. And we utilize the
Ingenix image which is available at Docker Hub.
And now it's time to move on to the next
step in our plan. And I promised you that
we will create a custom Docker image, push it
to Docker Hub, and afterwards grid deployment
based on this image. And that's what we'll
do next. But before doing that, let's remove
existing service and deployment in order to have
clean, let's say setup. So let's remove deployment
key delete deployment. And here will be
name of the deployment nginx deployment.
And also, let's delete series gate delete series
Ingenix deployment like that service was deleted
as well. Let's list now deployments gate get
deploy it the short version of the deployments,
no resources found, and let's list the services
gay get SVC just single default service with
named Kubernetes. We are good to go. And now
let's create a very basic Node js application.
They are we will utilize Express web server
package and create our custom web server.
Plan for this next step is following the rules
we will create no GS Express web application and
we will configure a web server in such a way that
it will respond with the hostname of the server.
When we connect to it using a root URL and such
way we will be able to distinguish which port
actually answers a specific request. We will also
Docker eyes such application using a Docker file
and Docker build command. And afterwards, push
build Docker image to Docker Hub. And finally,
we will create deployment using such customly
built image. You could find all final project
files in the GitHub repository, you'll find a link
to it right now here. But I highly recommend to
you to create such an application yourself even
if you don't know much about no GS and express.
And of course I recommend to you to build
your custom image and push to your Docker Hub
account. Of course, you could utilize images
available under My Account. They are public,
it's up to you. So let's no open Visual Studio
code. If you don't have it, please install it.
I'll open it up. And here in the Visual Studio
Code, please open up embedded terminal press key
combination Ctrl backtick like that terminal
was opened. And now let's create folder for
our project files. I will CD to desktop. And
here using make directory command I'll create
folder gate eight S stands for Kubernetes. As
you already know, let's see 2k eight s folder and
you could open any folder using code dot command
if you correctly installed Visual Studio code.
If such a command is not available on your
computer, you could press key combination
Command Shift B or Ctrl Shift B on Windows and
here enter gold and select Show command install
gold command in path and afterwards called
command will be available from any terminal.
So I have this command already available in the
past. That's why I'll open the K eight s folder
in the Visual Studio Code Editor. So called.it
will be opened in the new window like that.
Now this folder is completely empty and has no
files. Let me again open embedded terminal here.
It will be opened in K eight s folder. And now
here let's create folder for our first project.
And this folder name will
be let's say gay. eight s,
this web this Hello, because we will build a very
basic web application, which will simply respond
hello from Sarah and server name. So gay
a s web Hello. And here in this folder
we will create Node js application. Let's hear in
the terminal CD to K eight s web Hello folder like
that. And here are throws we will initialize Node
js application. And in order to do so you have to
install NPM on your computer. If you don't have no
GS and NPM available, please go to no GS download.
Here is link, download no Gs, and install no GS
from your computer, it will be installed along
with NPM. Of course, we will not run application
using Node js on our computers, we will
run application inside of the container
in the Kubernetes cluster instead.
But in order to initialize project locally,
and install dependencies, you have to use
NPM. So therefore, please install no GS
along with NPM. Afterwards NPM should
become available on your computer. I'll hide
this back pain. And now here let me NPM in it.
And I'll initialize this project. And you
could add here option dash y, which will
keep all answers to you during initialization of
the new node js project. So NPM in it, that's why
New Project was initialized. And here you
should find now package the JSON file with
such contents name of the project version and so
on. And now let's install a package called Express
and BM install Express. It will be
downloaded from the NPM registry
package was installed and package the JSON
file was updated here was no dependency called
Express. So now let's create the index js
file in our K eight s web Hello folder.
By the way, notice that now there was node modules
folder, which contains all dependencies of our
project. But now it is safe to simply remove this
folder, we don't need it anymore, because we will
not run this project locally with help of
node. So simply select this folder and delete.
All right, now we have only package the JSON
and package log the JSON files. Great. Now
let's create file and we will create it inside
of the gay eight s web Hello folder. So new file,
and let's name it index dot m j s y m because
we will utilize EF six modules syntax, which is
available in Node js starting from version 13.
And if you would like to use import statements,
instead of the require statements, you have to
name files with extension MJS. So let's create
file index dot MJS. And here I will not die per
contents of entire application, I will simply copy
them in order to save some time. So paste here. If
you would like you could of course write this very
tiny application yourself. So we import Express
from Express package. We also import oils from
oils oils is built in no GS module. And afterwards
we create Express application here is port 3000.
You could specify any other port if you would
like. And that's that port where our Express web
server will be running inside of the container.
Here we are adding a route handler for slash URL.
It is a route URL. And we simply answer to the
client with text Hello from their oils hostname
using oils package we retrieve hostname of the
server. And in the response from the server, you
will see simply text message hello from there and
name of the server where this application is run.
So arrests sent we sent to the client such
message and also we log it to the console.
And finally we start Express Web Server
Update listen, and we'll started at this port
3000 and the web server starts we will look to the
console message web server is listening at port
and here was port. I will not dive deeper in those
explanations and syntax of node GS because it is
not an old GS course. But you get an idea. We
create a very basic web server which will respond
with such text message. So let's save changes in
this file. Go CTRL S on Windows or Command S on
Mac like that changes were saved. And now let's
dock arise this application and for that we will
create a Docker file. Now I recommend to you to
install extensions called Docker and Kubernetes.
So go to Extensions here and enter throws Docker
here. Select Dogra and click Install. In my case,
Docker extension was already installed. And
afterwards please also installed Kubernetes
extension, find it like that and install it
as well. In my case, Kubernetes extension
was installed earlier. So now we are good to go.
And also, in order to build actual Docker image,
you have to run Docker on your computer. Before we
did not allow Docker in order to start a mini cube
Kubernetes cluster. But now we need Docker
in order to build Docker image. That's why
please go ahead and install Docker. If it is not
installed on your computer and or Docker download.
go to this link and install Docker
desktop which is available for Windows
Mac OS. And also you could install
Docker directly on Linux like systems.
So please go ahead and install Docker. afterwards.
Please run it I'll run it like that. I already
installed it before. Now here I see icon Dogra
is starting here I see information about that.
I'll wait a bit. Meanwhile, let's create a
Docker file inside of the K eight s web Hello
folder. Because we are creating no separate
obligation in the K eight s root folder.
So let's create a Docker file here new
file and name it Docker file like that.
Notice that Visual Studio Code recognize the type
of this file and it has added the icon Docker. And
here in the Docker file live add instructions
how we would like to build custom Docker image.
I'll again grab the contents of this Docker file
and paste here in order to save some time. And
there are following instructions. We will use Node
Alpine as a base image for our custom image. Here
we set working directory as slash up. Next, we
expose port 3000. Afterwards, we go up here to
files package the JSON and package the slug the
JSON which are present here. And then we run npm
install when we will build this custom image.
And after NPM installed, we are copying all the
remaining files from this folder where our Docker
file is located. In our example, it will be just
single file index dot NGS. And this file will be
quite a bit to the app folder inside of the image.
If you're not familiar with those steps, and don't
know what from Rockdoor, exports and so on mean,
I highly recommend you to find the Docker Crash
Course and go through it in order to understand
how Docker works and how you're able to build
custom images. This course is not a Docker course.
So we go through all the remaining application
files to target the folder up. And finally we
add instruction CMD that stands for command,
which actually indicates which command will
be executed when corresponding container based
on this custom rebuilt image will be started.
And we want to run npm start command.
But what happens now if we enter npm
start in our project folder. Let's try that.
Let's save those changes in Docker file, save.
And let's open up again embedded terminal. I
am still in K eight s web Hello folder. And
here in this folder there was index both in GS
file. And here let's enter npm start command.
And what I see I see missing script start.
Now our obligation will not allow anything
if you enter npm start command. In order to be
able to run our obligation start web server,
we need to modify package dot JSON file. Let's
do that. Let's open up package the JSON file and
here you will find scripts section and there
was just single default script test. Let's
actually replace test with start like that. And
here in double quotes type node index dot MJS.
So now there will be a start script
and it will essentially run using a
node file index both NGS. And this
will start actually our Express web server on
the port 3000. That's what we discussed here.
We have saved changes in package the JSON
file. Now NPM installed is available.
And we are able now to build our image. If you
want to create custom image you need to utilize
Docker build command. And usually this command
is entered in the folder where our Docker file
is located. That's this folder in our example
here, and if I list files and folders here, I
will find a Docker file. And Docker file contents
are here from work, dir expose and so on, do CMD
now, let's build a Docker image. And also we will
add tech to this customly built Docker image.
And that will include all the username of
your account at Docker Hub. If you don't
have Docker Hub account, please go to hub
docker.com and create account. I already
have an account and here is my username. Please
create your account and choose your username.
And afterwards, you will be able to push
repositories to Docker Hub under your account.
And when you push repositories, you will find
them here in the repositories section. Now,
under My Account, there are no repositories in
this namespace. So let's go back to Visual Studio
code. And here let's build a custom image for our
application. Let's use Command Docker build. Next
will be a path to Docker file. I'll use simply dot
because now I'm inside of the folder where Docker
file was created. So Docker build dot. Next,
let's add a tag to our image using the SD option,
then will be user name of your GitHub account.
In my case, I'll type mine. And after a slash,
I'll give name to the repository. Let's name
it same as we named this folder, gay eight s
that's web does Hello. Like that. Let's build this
image using Docker build command. Build an image
notice that in my case, base image was already
present in the cache and other layers were also
cached. And finally image was built. Now if
I enter command, Docker images and add grep
and here will be K eight s web I will find
image that is now available in our local images
repository. Here was name of the image which we
just built. That is latest because in this command
which I just entered, I did not specify tag which
you're able to specify after column here. But I
built image with later stack. So that's why tech
here is latest. And here is the ID of the build
image and size of the image. Now let's suppose
this cost only build image to Docker Hub. In
order to do so you have to first order to Docker
Hub. For that please enter command Docker login.
I already logged in before. That's why Docker
utilized cached credentials and login succeeded.
In your case if you enter Docker login for
the first time, you will be prompted to
enter Docker Hub login and password. Now I'm
able to push this build image to Docker Hub.
For that I'll utilize command docker push and here
will be the name of the image which I would like
to push to a remote repository hosting service.
Mr Xu K s web Hello. Let's go ahead and push it
using default deck latest pushing
the different layers of the image
it takes some time because image Israel too
large. So you see waiting for all those layers.
And finally this image was pushed to Docker
Hub. Let me verify that it appeared here.
Refresh page and now there was gate
eight s web Hello image. Wonderful.
This image by the way is public and
you're able to utilize it as well
for your Kubernetes deployments. Image is ready
and ready Add Docker Hub. And now we are able
to create the Kubernetes deployment based on this
image. Let's do that. Let's go to terminal here.
And let's create a new deployment. By the way,
now there are no deployments, Kay, get deploy.
No deployments gave, get SVC services, no
services, just single one Kubernetes. It
is default one. And now let's create a new
deployment based on customly built image.
For that, let's first utilize same command as we
used before, okay, great deployment. Okay, great
deployment. Let's name it A S. Web. Hello. And
the next will be option image. And image will
be be stashed up in my case, slash gay eight
s Web. Hello, same name, as it appears here
when I push the this image to the Docker
Hub, and the same name, as I see here.
So here's my user name. And here was
the name of the Docker repository.
Let's go ahead and create deployment based on
this image. Of course, if you performed all
steps yourself and push the customer build
image to Docker Hub under your account,
you could utilize here your username. So
let's go ahead and create new deployment.
deployment was created with K get pods. Now I see
that container creating status is status of this
port, which was created for this deployment.
Let's check again, still container creating,
because it takes some time to pull image from
Docker Hub. And now I see that container is run.
Right here is the name of the container. And here
was a hash of the replica set, which was created
by deployment. And here was specific hash for this
particular port. Now, let's create a service using
cluster IPL. And try to connect afterwards
to our web server, which is running using
no GS Express. So let's create service. For
that we will expose port key expose deployment.
Here will be name of the deployment gay eight
s Web. Hello. Next, let's add option prod
and recap that our Express web server is running
at Port 3000. Let's go back to our application.
Go to index dot NGS file. And here is this
port 3000. And we could basically expose it
to the same external port that will be used for
connections to deployment, let's utilize for
that just a single prod we will not need for that
target port option. That's why let's add this port
equal sign 3000 like that. And this will create
cluster IP for deployment K eight s web Hello.
Let's go ahead and create service
with least servicescape get SVC.
And here is a newly created service. Here was
name of the service and here was cluster IP,
which was created by Kubernetes. And again, using
such IP address, we will be able to connect to our
deployment, it means that you could connect to
any of the ports, you don't select which port
you will be connected to Kubernetes does this job
for you. And here we see that we opened port 3000
exposed port 3000. Let's try to connect to this
cluster IP and port 3000. Let me go up here this
cluster IP and of course, I will not be able to
connect to this cluster IP from my local computer.
That's why let's as usually quickly connect to
our mini cube node as a sage Docker at this IP
50 911. In your case, this IP is different.
Here. Our password is DC user. And now here
let's see URL to cluster IP and port 3000. That's
that port which were exposed from deployment. So
let's go ahead and I see message hello from
the gate eight s web Hello, and entire name
of the server where Express no GS application is
actually run. And that's that message which comes
from the Express web server here. That's where
we send it back to the client hello from the
and name host name of the session. over where this
obligation is run. And it means that everything
works perfectly. We created a deployment
based on the customly built image, which we
pushed to Docker Hub. And here a result of it and
we see response from the web server application.
Wonderful. By the way, if you enter a CRL command
like that, you will be automatically moved to the
new prompt, and you will stay on this line. If you
want to move to the new line, you could enter a C
URL, then add the semicolon and add here act like
that. And now you will be moved to the new line
here in the out. Wonderful. Now we got response
from the same port. Here we see same hostname,
as we saw here. Now, let's keep this window open
here. And let's increase quantity of the polls
in our deployment. Let's scale our deployment.
I'll open up a new tab in the item application,
you could open a new terminal window if you're
on Windows, I'll use key combination, Command
T in order to open new tab here. And here in the
new tab. If I enter key, I will say error command
not found because alias works only in this tab.
That's why let's create alias once again, alias k
equal sign cube CTL. By the way, you could omit
double quotes here, if a command consists only of
single word. So let me remove those double goals
like that. Alias was created. And now let's gay
get pods. And here I see same name of the board,
which I saw here in the answer from the web
server. Let's know scale this deployment. Recap.
The name of our deployment is K eight s web Hello.
Here's the name of the deployment. And now it
currently has just a single pod. let's scale it
K scale deployment. K eight s Web. Hello.
And I would like to scale deployment to
let's say four replicas. Let's go ahead,
deployment was scaled. Let's now get pods
K get pods. Now there are four ports, one is still
been created. Let's check back again. And now all
four ports are running. All of them belong to the
same deployment K eight s web Hello. And each port
of course has its own unique IP address. Let's get
details about ports, Gigabit ports, dash or white.
And here I see different IP addresses of each
port. And of course, they differ from the cluster
IP, which was created for a specific service.
With list services get SVC. And here as before,
we see cluster IP, 4k eight s web Hello service.
And each of those bolts is now available via this
cluster IP and Kubernetes will decide which
port to choose for each particular request.
Let's now go back to this step where
we are inside of the Kubernetes node
and try to make connections to this cluster IP
and this port again. Let's clear terminal here
and see URL. Now I see a response from this port
with such name. If I repeat command is a response
from another port. Let's repeat command once
again, once again, and so on. I see that now,
load is balanced across different ports. Because
here I see responses from different ports.
Different names appear here in the responses.
Different polls serve different requests. And
here are different names of the polls. That's
how distribution of the Lord works in action.
And now using search customly build Docker
image, we were able to prove that. Alright,
let's continue. And now let's modify type of the
service which we create for our deployment because
now there was cluster IP, which is available only
from inside of the cluster. Let's go here and
let's delete the current service K eight s web
Hello. Simply take its name was clear terminal
and antigay delete SVC stands for service and
based name of the service we would like to delete
service was deleted get SVC there was no such
service anymore. And if I tried to connect
again to deployment using cluster IP which we used
before, I will definitely get an error. So I see
No response. Great. Let's now create a service
again. But now we will set its type to node port.
Let's use send command K, expose deployment,
K eight s web Hello. And here will be type,
which will be set to node port. In
Pascal case notation node port. And let's
add here port option and brought will be set to
3000. Same port as we utilized before it is that
port where our containers actually run expressed
no GS application. Let's go ahead and create such
service of type node port deployment was exposed
Let's list services get SVC. And now there was
again service with name gate s web Hello, its type
now is note port. Here was again cluster IP, and
port. But here I see port which was specified here
using port option. And also after column I see
randomly created port 32,142. And now I am able
to connect to deployment using Node IP address,
I could get node IP address by entering mini cube
IPL, we have only single node recap. And here was
it a bit in my case. And I could take this IP at
this port. And I will connect to one of the ports
in this deployment. Let's do that. Let me
grab this IP, go to web browser for example.
Because now I will be able to connect to
deployment from my computer, let me paste this
IP and after column, I will add this port like
that. So in my case, connection string is here.
So here was AP address, it is IP address of
the node and here was randomly generated port,
which was created by Kubernetes itself when we
created service for our deployment. Let's go
ahead and try to connect. And I see response
from one of the ports. Let's refresh. And I
see response from other report with RS or name,
refresh again, and I see response from other port
here. That's how we are able to connect to our
deployment using node port service. Also, it is
more simple way to get the URL for connection to
this deployment by using mini cube service command
mini cube service. And here type name of the
service in our case, gay eight s web Hello.
Let's enter and new tab in the web browser will be
opened automatically. And notice URL here same as
I just used before IP address of the node and port
which was automatically generated by Kubernetes.
That's node port type of the service.
Also here you could see this actual URL when you
enter a mini cube service K eight s web Hello,
here was actual URL. And if you want to get only
URL, you could add here option does this URL
and you'll see only URL and you could
grab it and based it anywhere you want.
So that's a node port service type. And it
exposes the deployment at the port of the node.
And here was this specific port in my example, in
your case, this prod will be completely different.
And the one more option, which I would like to
show you in terms of creation of the service
is a load balancer. Let's create a load
balancer service and for that throws the
length delete existing service gate delete SVC
service gate s web Hello. Service was removed
gate gift SVC there was no more such service.
And let's create a service of type load balancer.
Gate expose the deployment. Gate s web Hello. Here
let's add type load balancer protocol Pascal Case
Foundation again, and let's add default option
and its value will be 3000. Same as before.
Let's create such service Service was created get
SVC. Now I see that there is service of type load
balancer. Here was cluster IP but external IP
here is pending. And you will see here pending
if you're using mini cube but when you deploy Your
applications somewhere in the cloud using one of
the cloud providers like Amazon, Google Cloud,
etc. Here you will see load balancer IP address
assigned automatically. But in our case, using
mini cube is behavior is similar to note port.
And here, we will still be able to connect to our
deployment using IP address of the node. And if
I enter now mini cube, service, gate s web Hello,
I will see connection which is made to IP address
of the node. And here was a game random brought
which was generated here. Here was this random
port. Alright, let's continue. And let's keep this
service and this deployment in place. Recap that
we have single service here which we created
before it is k eight s web hello and the SType
now is load balancer. And there are a single
deployment gate get deployed. And this name is
K eight s web Hello. And now this deployment
has four different ports available for us.
We could read the details about this deployment
Kay, describe deployment, gait s web Hello. And
here are the details of this deployment. By the
way, at the end here I see logs related to scaling
of replica set, initially, quantity of the
replica was one and later we scaled it to
four. If you want you could try to scale it
to any other number if you want to do so.
Above I see that this deployment has a name
gay as web Hello. namespace is default labels
annotation selector replicas desired for updated
for available for. And now let's try forming.
Let's try to update version of the image in
our deployment. Notice here that strategy type
is a rolling update. What does it mean? When
you release a new version of your application,
of course, you want to roll out this new version
in production smoothly without any interruption of
service. And Kubernetes allows that out of the
box. And this is very easy. And this strategy
type rolling update means that new ports will
be created with new image while previous ports
will be still running. So both will be replaced
one by one. And finally, in some time, or both
will be running in you updated image. And now
let's try that in action. We will update a bit
our application and the build new image with
NASA tech, for instance, version two dot 0.0.
And afterwards, we will modify image in our
deployment and see what will happen how Kubernetes
will roll out this update. So let's go ahead
and do that. By the way, I don't need this
step anymore, where I created SSH connection to
node. Therefore, let me exit from this connection
and the close this step actually, and I'll
keep only one tab open. So let's go back to
Visual Studio code. And here are contents of the
index dot MJS file. And we already have image
available for this version of the application
where server answers us with such string.
Now let's modify this twink for instance,
let's add here br ethics version two like that.
And let's know build a new image with a new tag,
push it to Docker Hub and afterwards modified
image in our deployment. Let's save changes in
this file, open up and better terminal. And let's
build image and assign another tag to eat. Now
image has only a single tag it is latest. So let's
build a new image Docker build dot dusty tech,
Mr. Chu prepend your name if you want to push this
version of the image to your Docker Hub account.
So base the sugar and here will be the name of the
image gay eight s web Hello. And after calm. I'll
add the tag for instance two dot 0.0 like that.
Let's build the site image recap that
I modified index dot NGS file and
I updated this string so it should build
new image. Let's go ahead and build it
building exporting layers image was built and
now let's push it to Docker Hub. I will Copy this
name, including the tech. And now here I enter
docker push. And a new version of my application
will be pushed using separate tech for the
same k eight s web Hello image. So let's go
ahead and push pushing, I see that some layers
already exist and only one layer was pushed to
image was pushed successfully, let me verify
that, go to my Docker Hub Account refresh
it still see just a single image
here. Notice, let me click on it.
And here I should find to tax
latest and do dot 0.0. Now let's
deploy this new version of this image. And
for that we will utilize following command.
Let's go to the terminal here. And let's
set a new image for the deployment key set
image. We are setting new image for particular
deployment next will be deployment name of the
deployment K eight s web Hello. And afterwards
we need to select ports where we would like to
set a new image. Here we will arrive at gate
eight s web Hello. And after equal sign we will
specify a new image. In my case it is bits the
shoe slash gay ID s web Hello, column two dot 0.0.
That's new tech which was assigned by us before we
push the new version of the image to Docker Hub.
After entering this command image will be
changed and roll out update will be started.
Be ready to enter follow in command after this
1k rollout status deployment K eight s web Hello,
you could prepare this command somewhere in
the text editor and afterwards quickly basted.
After this command, I'll try to enter it manually.
Let's go ahead and change image image updated
key rollout status deployment gay eight s web
Hello waiting for deployment allowed to finish.
And now I see the deployment successfully rolled
out. And before I saw such messages as three out
of four new replicas have been updated, one old
replicas are pending termination, and so on.
Finally, all previous replicas were terminated and
new replicas were rolled out. Let's know at least
bots gay get balls. And now I see that there
are four ports. And notice age of those ports
from 30 to 40 seconds, it means that previous
ports were fully terminated and new ports were
created. And now in all those four bolts, we
are running a new version of our application.
And we could verify that very easily by accessing
our deployment using service and there was still
service get SVC type of it is a load balancer.
And he was cluster IP here was brought. And by
entering command mini cube service, K eight s Webb
Hello, I could open connection to one of the run
ports. So let's go ahead and actually was opened
and now I see response, which includes version
two. That's how wrong updates work, you could
refresh page here, then you should see a response
from other server. For instance, this one. And
again, here I see version two, it means that
our new application version was successfully
deployed to all boats in the deployment.
Wonderful. That's where rolling updates and that's
how you could check status of the rolling update
by entering Command K rollout status. This one,
if you would like you could create the one Motek
for your image, push it to Docker Hub and verify
how rollout works again. Or if you want you could
roll back to previous version. By the way, we
could quickly try that together. Let's go to
this command and here I will remove deck and it
will mean that I would like to utilize only this
deck and let's check how image will be
modified again. And we are actually going back
to a previous version of our application. Let's
modify image let's chercher or allow status to
our default new replica have been updated, waiting
for deployment or allowed to finish. And finally,
deployment successfully rolled out. And again,
I will see four completely new ports, get pods,
here was age of those four ports.
Let's connect to our deployment again,
mini cube service gay it as web Hello. And I again
see hello from the server without version two.
That's where rolling updates. Wonderful.
Now, let's try fold. Now we have four bolts
up and run. But what happens if I
simply delete one of the ports manually?
Let's try that. Let's take for example, this
name of the port, notice H of those four ports,
and enter key delete port and paste name of
any port you like. And after this command,
let's get pods again. And I will see that new port
will be created automatically container created.
Because we told Kubernetes that desired
quantity of the ports in the deployment is four.
That's why it tries to do all his best to create
desired quantity of the replicas his specific
deployment. And now, I will see that there are
four ports again, up and running. And age of
this port is 33 seconds. All right, we try it
rolling updates. And also we tried to delete one
of the one ports. And don't let me demonstrate to
you how to lounge Kubernetes dashboard. If you're
using a community cube, it is very easy, just
single command. But if you're running Kubernetes
on your own premises, or somewhere in the cloud,
it could be a bit more difficult, because you need
to secure web access to dashboard. But here again,
there's just single command mini cube dashboard.
Like that, let's enable this broad
lounging proxy verifying proxy hells.
And this broad web page will be opened here.
And as you saw here, no prompt for user name and
password. This dashboard was simply launched like
that, because we are using mini cube. And here you
could observe the details about your Kubernetes
cluster. For example, you could go to deployments,
and you will find a single deployment here
notice Let me decrease a bit on size like that.
So here is metadata for this deployment.
Here are labels. Strategy rolling update,
that's what we observed. Both status for
available for updated. Here are conditions
new replica set, here was ID of the replica
set, which was created by this deployment.
You could click on this hyperlink and read the
details about specific replica set. Notice that
replica set deployment and ports all
belong to the same namespace default,
but of course, you could assign
deployments to different custom namespaces
labels for this replica set port status for
running for desired and here are links to
all boats which belong to this particular
replica set. Also below there was service
which was created for this replica set for
this deployment type is a load balancer here.
And if you click on specific port, you could
read the details about a particular port
here is name of the port namespace when port
was created. Here is information about the
node where this boat was created status is
running IP address of the port. Below you
could also find the details about replica set
which actually controls this particular port.
And notice that the label for this port is here
up Golang K eight s web Hello. And the same label
is found here controlled by replica set
and here was label in the replica set.
Also below you might find the details about
events which happened in this particular port.
For example, here is step pulling
image Mr. Xu K eight s web Hello.
And here are the deals about containers
which are no running inside of the port.
There was no just a single container inside of
each port. By the way, if I go to replica sets,
I will find actually two different replica sets
which were created for different images for this
image and for this image. And now in this
replica set there are zero point because we
rolled back from this image to this image with
Tag latest, that's why now here I see four ports,
and here, zero ports. Alright, this graphical
user interface, you could click on other menu
items and observe which, for example, nodes belong
to the classroom. Now there was a single mini cube
note. And if you click on it, you could read
the details about this particular node. That was
Kubernetes dashboard. And you could utilize it
in order to observe status of the Kubernetes
deployments and services, and so on. Let me close
it. And now let's continue and the left Ctrl C in
order to interrupt this process here. And now mini
cube does brought will not be available anymore.
Now, important notice, we just used imperative
approach to creation of deployments and
services. And we create deployments and
services using different cube CTL commands.
But usually, that's not the way how
deployments and services are created.
And in most cases, declarative approach
is utilized. And in declarative approach,
you have to create Yamo configuration files,
which describe all the details for deployments
and services. And afterwards, apply those
configuration files using cube CTL. Apply command.
And that's actually declarative approach of
creation of different resources and objects in
Kubernetes. And that's what we will do right now.
Let's now delete both deployment and service which
we created before. And for that, you could do the
alias command, cube CTL, delete the deployment,
and afterwards, delete service. But there was
also a short version of deletion of all resources
in default namespace, and it is gate delete
all with option, there's there's all like that
all the resources will be deleted, you'll see
that both were deleted, service was deleted,
and deployment was deleted as well. Let's
get pods. Both are still being terminated.
Let's check again. Still terminating was
wait a bit. And now there are no resources
found in default namespace. All ports were
terminated, let's get services get SVC.
And now there was only a single default system
service Kubernetes. And of course, there are no
deployments get deployed, no resources found.
Now let's create Yamo configuration file
for deployment. And for serious heroes, we will
create two separate configuration files. Let's
go to Visual Studio code. And here, let me by the
way, height and by the terminal for the moment.
And let me close those old windows. And now here,
let's collapse this folder gay eight s web Hello,
because this folder was dedicated to
our Node js Express web application.
And now here in the root of the K eight s
folder here, let's create the following files
deployment both Yamo. And also let's create
file service dot Yamo. Like that. So two files
deployment Yamo and service dot Yamo. Let's
throws the field in deployment dot Yamo file.
If you installed Kubernetes extension here in
VS code, what I asked you to do before you could
create such configuration files very fast. Let
me show you. So type here simply deployment
and you will see suggestion Kubernetes
deployment we have selected and you
will see that Yamo configuration file
will be created automatically for you.
And you will see that all appearances of the my
app will be highlighted and you could simply type
name of the deployment which you would like to
set and left set name to K eight s same as we did
before. But now we are using Yamo configuration
file. So K eight s web Hello. Like that.
deployment name was set here was actual name for
this deployment. He was a diversion ops slash v1.
Here was selector with match label scheme. And
by this match label scheme, we specify which
poles will be managed by this deployment. And
below there was nested template and this template
describes actually port but here you don't need
To specify kind of the template like that, because
this nested template for deployment template is
always bought. Therefore, current here is not
needed. Next, for the ports which belong to this
deployment, here, we set labels. And label here is
the same as label here in selector match labels.
So this label and this label match here. And next
in spec give, we specify which containers we want
to create in this port. And there was just single
container with such name image is to be filled,
we will replace this image placeholder now with
real image. And also below, you could specify
which ports you would like to open in specific
container. And below in the port section, you
could specify a list of the container ports,
which will be open on the ports IP address. So
let's feel now the details in this spec section.
image will be based Ashok slash K eight s web
Hello. And both here will be contained in Port
3000. Like that. Also notice that VS code
Kubernetes extension added resources section here.
And in this section, there was limit skip, which
specify memory and CPU limits for each board,
which will be created by this deployment. And
here will limit amount of memory and amount of CPU
resources. 500 m means half of the CPU core. If
you want to modify 500 to 250, for example, 1/4 of
the CPU core, let's keep it like that. And that's
it for this specification of the deployment.
Let's save changes in this file. And now let me
actually show how to find documentation on how to
create specific Yamo configuration files. Let's go
to web browser and here let's go to kubernetes.io.
And go here to documentation. And here or go
to reference. And here, select Kubernetes API.
And in Kubernetes API, you could select
for example, workload resources. And you
will find the details how to describe for example
ports, or create port template or create replica
set, we just create a deployment. Therefore, let's
click on deployment section here. And you will
find the details how to create Yamo configuration
files. If you want to create a deployment,
a diversion must be set to apps slash v1. And
below you will find other keys which must be
present in deployment configuration file. For
example, client must be set to deployment. Then
there was metadata section spec status status, by
the way, is filled by Kubernetes automatically,
and it will be added after you create deployment
based on specific configuration file. And if I
go back to configuration file here, I will find
such keys as API version kind metadata and spec,
same keys which are described here API version
kind metadata and spec. And if you want to get
details about deployment spec, you could click
here and you will find that inside of the spec,
you have to specify a selector template
replicas, strategy mean radio seconds and so on.
And if I have a look at this back here, I will
find out that inside of spec in this example,
there are a selector and template selector
and template here, and both are required.
If you click on template, you will read the
details about both template spec. Let's click
on it. And here you will find that inside of the
board template spec, you have to specify metadata
and spec we just bought a spec. And that's what we
added here in the template section, metadata and
spec for the pod. Let's click on pod spec and read
the details about pod specification containers is
required and you could add multiple containers
in the pod specification if you want to do so.
And here in this spec we have containers
here it is let's click on container here.
And in this container specification you will find
name which is required. That's why we set name as
this all Also you have to set image for a specific
container. Here with image resources and ports are
also described here on this recommendation
page. So here we support section. Also,
you could set for instance, environment variables
for a particular container. I highly recommend to
you to get familiar with documentation, and with
all options available, and I just demonstrated
to you how you could dig through documentation
and find out how to feel different sections of
the configuration file. Alright, we are done with
creation of the configuration file for deployment.
So current here is deployment. And let's now
apply this configuration file using declarative
approach, creating such file in place, you
will no longer required to enter command
cube CTL create deployment, you will just
enter command cube CTL apply. Let's do that.
Let's open up embedded terminal here. And now
I'm still inside of the gate eight s web Hello
folder. Let me go out of this folder where this
deployment Yamo file is located. Let's least files
here. So here is deployment Yamo configuration
file. And here let's enter command cube CTL.
Apply this F stands for File, and here
will be the name of the file deployment.
Dot Yamo. Simple as Det file was
applied and deployment was created
was generated. By the way here I don't have
alias with adequately alias, alias K, cube CTL.
So K get deployments. And now there
was K eight s web Hello deployment.
And there was single port in this deployment get
ports. Here's this port, which is up and running.
Right. But how we could now scale this deployment
and increase quantity of the replicas were easily
by modification of this specification file. But
how we could increase quantity of the replicas.
Here at the moment, we don't see any numbers.
Let's try to find out that using documentation.
I assume that I don't know how to change that. So
let's go to work load resources, check deployment
and scroll down here. So spec status metadata
kind, no options here. Let's click on deployment
spec. Here we'll select or template replicas
number of desired ports. And that's that option
which you need to utilize if you want to modify
quantity of the replicas from default number one,
oh here was default number one to any other
number. And you have to add replica Skee
in the deployment spec. So let's go to
deployment spec. So here we spec. And here,
let's add new deal replicas. And its value
will do let's say number five. If I go back,
I could read that its value is integer 32. So you
don't need to write here file like that. Right.
As a number, we have save changes. And let's apply
this deployment Yamo configuration file again,
using same command cube CTL, apply
this F deployment Yamo. Let's go ahead
configured, get pods. And now I see that four
new containers are being created. And now
my deployment has five different
ports, four of them are already already
know five around. That's how we
were able to very easily modify
our deployment simply by modification of
the deployment Yamo configuration file.
But of course now there are no services K get SVC
let's create a new service using similar approach.
Let's hide them by the terminal. And let's
now go to service dot Yamo configuration file.
And here I'll let's also speed up the process
for creation of the service configuration
file and type service and Kubernetes extension
will offer us this option. And this spec will
be graded automatically. Client is service API
version is b one here it differs from API version
for deployment kind metadata name sets name for
this service. Let's enter name gate s web hello
and also hero let's modify selector and
select all will be up Golden Gate eight s
web Hello as well. By the way If you hover mouse
over any of the keys in this configuration file,
you could find hyperlinks to documentation for
each particular key, for example, key name URL is
here. Or if you hover mouse over kind, you could
also find hyperlinks here for a diversion for kind
of metadata, for instance. All right, what is left
here in this series is modification of the port
section. Here, I see that port and target port
were our auto populated. Before we utilize the we
exposed actually same port 3000, which is the
port where our Express web server is running.
And now we could try different port expose Port
3000, which is target port to port, let's say
3030, like that. And it means that
target port 3000 will be exposed
to external Port Authority authority. Also
notice that in this specification, there was no
type for this service. And let's say that
we want to create a load balancer service.
For that, let's go to documentation. Let's find
documentation for service here. Kubernetes, API,
service resources, service. And here are let's
click on service specification. Here we'll select
Reports. And also below you could find type of the
service type, either cluster IP, which is default,
or external name, or node port or load balancer.
Let's set type to load balancer. Let's go back
to our configuration file. And here inspect,
let's set type to load balancer like that.
That's it for this service specification. Let's
save changes in this file. And let's apply this
using same command as before cube CTL. Apply dash
F stands for File, and here are type service dot
Yamo. I'm still inside of the gate eight s
folder. So let's apply a service Yamo file
applied GAE get SVC. And now I see that new
service with type load balancer was created.
And now similarly, as before, I could
open connection to our deployment
using command mini cube service K eight s Web.
Hello, let's go ahead and page will be opened.
Refresh and a good response from another port. It
means that now everything works as before, there
was no service and deployment. And we created
everything using declarative approach using
configuration files. He was filed for service and
here's file for deployment. We could also very
easily delete deployment and service which we just
created using just one command. Let's do that, go
to the terminal and here enter key delete this f
here will be the name of the first file deployment
Yamo. And here, let's add dash f option once again
and type of service that Yamo. Let's go ahead
and delete both deployment and service. We'll
check okay, get SVC no service, get deployment
and no deployment. Great. Now let's do following.
Let's try to create two deployments. And let's
connect them with each other. Because it's very
common task when you want to connect different
obligations together for example, connect front
end to back end or connect back end to database
service and so on. Therefore, now we will do
following let me draw a picture. So similarly as
before, we will create a web deployment and deploy
their our no GS Express web application. And here
let me type web like that. And also we will create
one more deployment and we will name it Ingenix.
This Ingenix deployment will run
basic nginx image with no adjustments
and this nginx deployment will have corresponding
service with cluster IP. So let me draw here a
line and here will be in Gloucester IBM will
start with capital C cluster IP like that. And
those two deployments of course are allocated
in the Kubernetes cluster. And this deployment
will be also exposed but each service will have
type Load Balancer, it means that we will be
able to connect to either from outside using load
balancers IP address here with a load balancer.
Now, inside of the web application, we will create
two endpoints, first will be route and point,
same as before, which will return simply
hello from the web server. And one more
endpoint here will be, let's say Ingenix.
And when connection will be made to nginx,
we will connect to nginx service by using cluster
IP. Or you will see that using nginx service name
like that. So from one deployment,
we will connect to another deployment
and get response from one of the ports
which will be run in nginx application.
And afterwards, we will return back result to
the client with the contents which we received
from the engineer and export. So that's the
plan. And in such way, we will actually connect
to different deployments, web deployment and
nginx deployment. Let's get started with that.
You're inside of the K eight s folder. Let me
close those files for the moment. Let's create
a copy of this folder K eight s web Hello, which
contains all files related to our Weber Express
application. Let's copy this folder and paste
here. And let's rename it simply click on this
name, press enter and enter a new name K eight s
web to Ingenix like that. Next, let's keep Docker
file unmodified, Kira Coulter's have this Docker
file in this folder, so no modifications here,
but we will slightly modify index dot MGS file.
And I will grab a modified file from here. Let me
copy it and paste here. So here are the contents
of index dot MGS file for this second application.
There is still route URL here forward
slash, we still great Express web seller.
But we add here one more endpoint Ingenix. And its
route handler is now async function because now we
will connect to another server simulating
connection between different deployments.
And notice URL here it is simply
http colon slash slash Nginx.
And we will create a service called
Ingenix. For second nginx deployment.
And from this deployment, we will be
able to connect to another deployment
using just name of the corresponding service.
Simple as that. Of course, it is possible to
connect using either cluster IP or not cluster
IP is dynamic name of the service is static. So
we will connect to one of the nginx servers by
using nginx service name. And here, we utilize
fetch, which we import from node fetch package,
by the way, in the moment, we will install it
in this application as well. So we are waiting for
response from the engine X server. And afterwards,
we take body from the response calling text
method and simply return to the client, this body
essentially what this endpoint will do, it will
simply proxy request to the nginx server and
return a result response from the Ingenix to the
client. Simple as that. And here we import fetch
from node fetch, therefore, we have to install
such external dependency. And for that, let's open
up another terminal and the here make sure that
you see deep to this folder, gate s web to Nginx.
Web to Nginx. And here let's enter npm
install Node fetch installing package
you will see that this package
the JSON file will be modified.
So now here are two dependencies Express and node
fetch dependency was installed. And notice again,
that node modules folder has appeared here but
we don't need it here. Let's simply remove it
because inside of the image, which we will build
right now, we have instruction to run npm install.
Here it is. That's why all necessary dependencies
will be installed inside of the Docker. image. All
right, now we are good to go. By the way, this
application is also included in the final project
files, which you could clone from my GitHub
repository. So K eight s web to Nginx. And here
was index dot MJS file. And now let's again build
the Docker image, but it will be in your Docker
image from this application. And now let's build
it using the same command as before Docker build.
So let's list files and folders here there was
a Docker file. Docker file was not modified,
it is the same as for previous application. And
now let's build Docker image Docker build dot.
And let's add a tag, Mr. Ashok, slash, and let's
name it gay eight s web two Ingenix. Same name as
for this folder. And let's keep tag as latest.
You don't have to add here tag like that. In
this case, it will be added automatically. So
let's build such image image is being built
notice npm install command image was built. And
now let's push it to Docker Hub. Let me grab
this name. docker push. And here will be the name
of the image which I want to push to Docker Hub
pushing some of the layers will be reused from our
image. And finally image was pushed and now we are
able to utilize it in Kubernetes deployment.
Great, let's hide the terminal and no less
the following. Now I would like to demonstrate
you how you could combine deployment Yamo and
service Yamo configuration files just in one file.
Let's close those files. And let's create a new
file and let's name it K eight s web to nginx dot
Yamo. Like that. Now in this configuration file,
we will combine instructions for creation of
the deployment and service. Let's first go
to service dot Yamo. Take contents of this file
and paste here in the gate s web to nginx Yamo.
Afterwards, please add three dashes
exactly three and go to the next line.
Now let's go to Yamo file for the deployment with
take all its contents and paste here under those
three dashes. And now just in single file, we have
specification, both for service and deployment.
Now let's modify deployment because we would
like to utilize our other image and here we
will utilize our other name. By the way, we could
select this name here, then right button click
and select Change all occurrences. And let's
name service and deployment as gay eight s
web to Ingenix. Like that. Let's keep
type for this service as a load balancer
port here could be modified to another for
instance, let's set it to all three like that. And
here in the deployment specification, let's
decrease quantity of the replicas to let's say
three. And also let's modify specification for
containers. And the image which we would like
to use right now will be K eight s web to engine X
it was replaced when I modified the K eight s web
Hello name. So he was correct image which we
just pushed to Docker Hub and this image we would
like to utilize for this particular deployment.
And container port will be unchanged this 3000
Alright, that's it for specification for
deployment and service for new application.
And now let's create the specification for NJ MCs
deployment and service because we will deploy now
two different applications. One which will
be based on our custom image and second,
which is based on official Docker image called
Nginx. Let's simply copy this file and paste here.
And let's name this file as nginx dot Yamo. And
now in this nginx dot Yamo file. Let's modify
names. Once again select this and change all
occurrences. And let's name it simply Ingenix.
Please type exactly as I just did. Exactly Ingenix
because this name for the service we will utilize
inside of our deployment inside of our containers
which are running Express no GS web server.
We will connect to this deployment by using
Ingenix service name. That's why this name is very
important here. Now, we decided to utilize cluster
IP service type for this second deployment.
That's why let's remove type load balancer from
here. By default cluster IP will be assigned
here. And let's modify ports section here, let's
remove target port and keep only port and set it
to eight. It is default port where Ingenix will
run web server. Also in the deployment section,
we have to modify image. And now it will
be simply Ingenix without your user name,
because we would like to utilize the default nginx
image. Let's keep resource limits here in place,
and let's modify here container port to add like
that. So quantity of the replicas will be for
instance five instead of three. Let's save changes
here and delete summarize what we did here,
we will create a new service called Nginx.
And name here is important for our setup.
Here is a port section with single key port.
And that means that external port A will
be mapped to internal port 80. It is port
where nginx web server is run by default.
And service type here is cluster IP,
it means that such service will not be
available outside of the Kubernetes cluster.
And here in this deployment, we utilize
official Docker image called Nginx. Here
a specification of for the port containers
and container port is set to eight. That's
it. So we created the two Yamo configuration
files nginx dot Yamo and K eight s web two
Ingenix which utilizes customly built image.
Here's this image name. And now let's apply
both configuration files, this one and this one.
Let's go to the terminal and verify that now
we don't have any deployments get deploy.
No deployments at the moment, and no services. And
now let's deploy everything using just a single
command. Now I'm still inside of the K
eight s web to engine X folder. Let's go
one level up where our Yamo configuration
files are located. Here they are,
this one and this one. And let's apply them.
Okay, apply this f here will be first file.
Here is its name. And we could also
apply one more file, this F Ingenix Yamo.
Like that. Let's go ahead and create
both deployments and both services.
Service created deployment created
service created and deployment created.
Let's check deployments gay get deployed. There
are now two deployments, this one and this one.
Partially, they already get the SVC.
Let's read information about services.
There are two services which were created this one
which has type load balancer, and nginx, which has
type cluster IP recap that we will connect from
this web to nginx deployment to nginx deployment
using this name for the service. Or we could
also utilize cluster IP in order to connect
from one deployment to another. But cluster
IP is dynamic. This service name is static.
So let's also check boards game get pods. Some of
the polls are running and one is still pending.
And now we are able to test our setup and try to
connect from web application from web deployment
to nginx deployment. Let's open connection
to our web service deployment because we
used here a load balancer type for this service.
And we could utilize this port here an IP address
of the Kubernetes node. Recap that in order
to quickly get a URL for a specific deployment
using mini cube you could enter command mini cube
service and here will be the name of
the service K eight s web two Ingenix.
Web browser page was opened and we got response
from one of the ports which belongs looks to
K eight s web to nginx deployment. And here
is the name of the corresponding replica set.
Alright, we just triggered connection to root URL.
Let's go back quickly to our application. Let me
hide this terminal here. And let's go to this
new application and open index dot m. JS file.
And recap that here we have two endpoints
root endpoint, and slash nginx endpoint,
which will essentially send request to nginx
URL, this one and return back to the client
proxy response from other server. This server
is external relative to this server where we
are running this web application. We just
received this stream from the server,
let's not try to connect to Ingenix endpoint.
Let's go back to our browser and add here
slash Nginx. Press Enter. And what I got, I got
Welcome to Nginx. It means that the response from
the nginx Sarah was proxy successfully inside of
the server, which belongs to our web deployment.
And we were able in such way to connect
from one deployment to another deployment
by the name of another service. So nginx, here
is name of another service as we specified here.
And such service has no cluster IP, get SVC.
So here is cluster IP for nginx service.
And we were able to connect to another deployment
by name of the service. That's how you could very
easily connect different deployments together.
And such a resolution of the service name to IP
address is performed by internal service
of the Kubernetes, which is called DNS.
And we could actually verify that quickly.
Let's go to the terminal for example here.
And recap, the week would still get here list
of the ports K get pods. And now we could take
any of the pods and execute any commands inside
of the running container inside of the pod.
Using cube CTL. Exec command, this command is
very similar to Docker exec command. Let's now
take the name of any port which belongs to k s
web to nginx deployment. Let me copy this name in
your case names will be completely different. And
let me clear our terminal here and enter K exec
here will be name of the port. Next will be two
dashes. And afterwards, let's type NS lookup
in Janux. Like that, let's press Enter. And
I got foreign corresponds. What does it mean?
Using this command? We tried to resolve
NJ leaks name from inside of the container
which belongs to the sport and such resolution
was successful. And this IP address which I got
from the DNS server when I made request and as
lookup Ingenix. But where does this IP come from?
With right gay get SVC. And here I get such
a view. And notice that this IP is the same
as this one. And that's what I told you. Now
Kubernetes is able to resolve name of the service
to corresponding cluster IP. And that's what
we see here. And we performed resolution
inside of the port which belongs to our
deployment and our other service. And of course,
I could execute similarly command in one of
the ports for example, I could type here,
we get there skew all this and here type http
Ingenix. And this will actually connect to Nginx.
Sarah, then retrieved from it
route web page. Let's try that.
And I successfully received response from one of
the Ingenix ports. And here was nginx web page.
Alright, this how different deployments could
be very easily connected with each other.
Let's go back to Visual Studio code and let's
delete everything what we have so far. If you
want to dive deeper and To explore details about
those deployments, you could do that of course,
now you could allow it for instance, mini cube
dashboard, you could dig deeper, go to different
ports and explore what happens inside of them and
so on. You have all necessary knowledge for that.
Alright, now let's delete both deployments
and both services. Delete this F
Ingenix dot Yamo and dash f gay it s
web to nginx dot Yamo. Let's go ahead,
both services and deployments were deleted, gay
get deployed. No resources found gay get as we see
just single service. I think you would agree with
me that deployment using Yamo configuration files
is a much more pleasant and faster than
deployment using separate cube CTL commands.
We are done with main practical part of this
course. And one step left. And I would like to
demonstrate to you how to change container runtime
which is currently darker in our Kubernetes
cluster to other container on time for instance,
CRI o or container D and in order to modify
container runtime we need to delete current
mini cube set up and create a new one. But let's
go to the terminal here. And let's enter mini
cube status command. Now it is running cubelet is
running a barrier service is run. Let's no stop,
mini cube mini cube stop stopping node mini cube
one node was stopped and now let's delete
current set up mini cube delete the
little mini cube in virtual box in my case I
removed all traces of the mini cube cluster. Now
let's create Gloucester over again. Mini cube
start I will again use driver option and its
value will be virtual box in my case. If you're a
Windows user, you should type here Hyper V same as
for previous mini cube start. But please note is
that Docker option did not work for me at least,
I wasn't able to run CRI o containers inside of
the Docker container. So for some reason it didn't
work. Therefore I utilize VirtualBox and they
don't recommend you to use now. Driver Docker.
So driver is VirtualBox in my case. And next
I will add option. There's this container
this runtime and this value will be CRI
this oh one more option is container D.
You could try both if you want to do so. So I will
enter here CRI o like that. And let's create a
mini cube cluster from the scratch once
again. But now container run time is set
to CRI o let's go ahead start in control plane
node mini cube in the classroom mini cube again
creating real doll books. It will take a while
now I see step preparing Kubernetes on CRI oh
and finally it was done. Let's now
check the status mini cube status.
Type Ctrl Blaine host is running everything is
run same as before. But now container run time
inside of the node is CRI O. Let's check that.
Let's SSH to minikube IP address and let's enter
here throws mini cube IBM SSH Docker at 192 168
59. One auto Yes, DC user. Now I'm inside of
the mini cube node. And now let's enter docker ps.
And what I see I see cannot connect to the Docker.
And it is an indication that Docker is not running
inside of this node, because we are using CRI
o container runtime instead. But how to
check whether there are CRI o containers.
Were easily using the following command sudo
CRI CTL PS and here are a bunch of different
containers which are running like do proxy
core DNS storage provisioner and so on. Now
let's try again to deploy both applications web
application and nginx application and create
both services and see how it goes. Let's
go back to results. To the code. And here,
let's perform the same task as before. Simply
apply configuration gate, applied this F and
apply both Yamo configuration files. Well, let's
go ahead created deployments and created services
gate get deploy. Not ready yet, but
there are two deployments. Once again,
again, not ready, let's get information about
services. There are two services same as before,
gate, get pods. Some of the posts
are instead of container creating
one expanding love check a
game. Some are already running.
Gay get deploy for AWS to deployment is radio
Ingenix is not yet ready. Let's check again.
Now nginx is partially ready. And now all those
containers were created by CRI o container
runtime. Let's enter a mini cube service and
name of the service in order to test whether
everything works as before. So here was response
from one of the polls. And let's add here slash
Ingenix. And same as before it works. Now
we were able to poke through response from
the engine X deployment. Wonderful. We
just modified the container runtime.
And now it is set to CRI oh, let's go back
to this SSH connection where we connected to
node. And here let's enter again. Sudo CRI CTL
PS. And let's for example, grab by the name,
K eight s web two Ingenix. And I see now three
different containers which belong to this
deployment. And now they are arriving using CRI.
Oh. Alright, let's no disconnect from this server.
Alright guys, that's it for this Kubernetes for
beginners course. You could of course keep your
mini cube cluster running. You could create other
deployments, you could build other Docker images.
In other words, play with Kubernetes as you want
and get familiar with all Kubernetes tools which
we discussed in this course. I hope you enjoy this
course and I hope you enjoyed spending time with
me. If so, you could find me in the social media
networks all links you'll find here on the screen
and I will be more than happy to meet you in
other videos and I wish you all the best. Bye bye